PROFESSOR: OK.
That is the first step.
But to make things
really clear, we
have to do the second step that
it involves the Bi solution.
So let me say something
about Bi as well.
So Bi has similar
asymptotic expansions.
A Bi solution, if psi, you
have an exact Bi solution.
When psi on the left would
behave as minus 1 over pi,
this is for u negative.
1 over u to the 1/4 sine of 2/3
u to the 3/2 minus pi over 4.
And psi on the right
of x would behave as 1
over square root of pi,
1 over u to the 1/4, e
to the 2/3, u over 3/2.
OK.
This is the asymptotic
behavior of B. So
what's noteworthy about it?
First, that it oscillates
for u negative.
That's to the left.
It oscillates.
Instead of a cosine, a
sine, the same phase shift.
And then that on the other side
for u positive, it blows up.
So it uses the
other exponential.
And this all is reasonable.
And in fact, it allows
you to connect as well.
So in this case, we would have
this term looks like this one.
And the left one looks like--
so indeed, if you
had the Bi solution,
the matching requires
that the D term over there
is matched to the B term
over here because that's how
the Bi solution is connected.
So we now need to
relate the B to the D.
So I will write down
the relation here.
So in this case,
there's no factor of 2,
but there is a minus sign.
So we have B must
be equal to minus D.
So you can take B equals to
minus 1 and D equals to 1.
And we get 1 over square root
of kfx sine x to A. Kfx prime dx
prime minus pi over 4 connects
in principle to minus 1
over square root of kappa of x
e to the integral from A to x,
kappa of x prime dx prime.
I think I have it all right.
B is there.
B is minus 1.
It's over there.
D is equal to 1.
That's the D term.
That's the other
connection condition.
OK.
So the technicalities are gone.
But the concept now requires
a serious discussion.
I'll give you a little
time to take it in.
We've connected every functions.
That was the first work
we did at the beginning
of this lecture.
We did, in the top blackboard
justify, this expansions.
We discussed how the Bi function
would originate from a counter
integral as well.
And we didn't derive the
Bi asymptotic expansions,
but they're similarly derived.
And then we used those
to connect things.
And now the question is whether
these equations can be used.
If I know the solution
on the left is like that,
can I say the solution on
the right is like that?
Or if I know the solution
on the right is like that,
can I say the equation
is on the left?
And the same thing here.
If I know the
solution on the left,
do I know the
solution on the right?
And if I know the
solution on the right,
do I know the
solution on the left?
Now it looks like yes,
that's what you derive.
But remember, it's
not quite simple
because our whole discussion
assume that OK, the potential
is strictly linear.
But in reality, the
potential starts to deviate.
So these things
that were right here
are not exact
asymptotic expansions.
That is the exact dominant term
of the asymptotic expansions.
But here there
may be extra terms
because the solution
does not correspond
to a potential is
exactly linear.
And anyway, this is
not an exact solution
of the differential equation.
So there is a possibility
of ambiguities here
that actually indicate
the following.
I claim this connection can
only be done in this way.
You can only take this equality
from the right to the left.
That is, if you
know that you just
have a decaying
exponential, you know
it connects to this function.
Why?
Because if you know you
have a decaying exponential,
there's 0 chance
there is a growing
exponential on the right.
You may have a barrier
that extends forever,
and there's definitely only
a decay in exponential,
however the barrier looks.
If there's only a
decaying exponential,
you know that this growing
exponential is just not there.
The coefficient here is 0.
So you don't have the
ambiguity that maybe you
have a little bit of a
growing exponential that
connects to this.
So you can go from
here to there.
On the other hand, you
cannot quite go from the left
to the right.
Why is that?
The reason is the following.
If you just know
this is on the left,
you would say, OK, now I predict
a decaying exponential there.
But your calculation
is not totally exact,
so there could be an
infinitesimal wave
of the other type on the
left, an infinitesimal wave
of this kind.
But that infinitesimal
wave of this kind
goes into a growing exponential,
and a growing exponential
eventually overtakes this
one and ruins your solution.
So you cannot really use this
equation from right to left.
The small possibility of
error on the left side,
because you don't
have exact solutions,
translates into an
ambiguity concerning
a positively
growing exponential,
and it would overtake this.
So if you say oh, I
have this, therefore I
have this decaying
exponential, this
may be a very inaccurate
thing because maybe you
have a little bit
of the sine that you
didn't see because it was
much smaller than this term.
But that would give you
a growing exponential.
So you cannot use that
equation in that direction.
Similarly here, you
have another direction.
The direction is this one.
It's crucial.
You can go that way, but you
cannot go the other direction
as well.
And the reason is
kind of similar.
Suppose you have
here, you say, OK,
I have this growing exponential.
And say somebody comes in, no,
there's a little bit of cosine
here.
And you say well, but
a little bit of cosine
gives me a decaying
exponential that is irrelevant
compared to this one.
So you are safe in going
from this side to that side.
You're going into
growing exponential.
Any error on the left
will produce a small error
on the right.
Of the other hand, you
cannot go, honestly,
from right to left because
if you had a decaying
exponential-- this is
a growing exponential.
If you had the
decaying exponential,
you wouldn't see it here.
This one takes over.
But the decaying exponential
produces a nice cosine
that is quite
comparable to this one.
So a decaying exponential
that you don't see here
produces on this side a term
that is comparable to this one.
So you also cannot go from this
direction to that direction.
So these are the
connection formulas
and these are the directions.
We've done this for this
configuration in which we have
a turning point of this form
at the point A, in which you're
allowed to the left and
forbidden to the right.
For convenience, it's
useful to have a formula--
let's go here-- where you have
the opposite direction in which
you have a B here, and you
have allowed to the right
and forbidden to the left.
I will write those formulas
because they are many times
used and you will
need them in general.
And Griffiths and other
books don't have the patience
to give you all the formulas.
This is kappa of
x prime, vx prime.
This is growing or
decaying exponential?
This should be called
the growing exponential
on the left.
This is the forbidden region.
As x becomes more and more
left, the interval is bigger.
So this is a growing
exponential on the left.
1 over k of x sine b to x,
k of x prime, vx prime minus
pi over 4.
And this one, again,
just like that one,
you go into the
growing exponential.
So that's that relation.
And I kind of write these
things following this picture.
So you're allowed to the right
and forbidden on the left side.
The allowed way
function the right,
the forbidden way
function to the left.
1 over kappa of x,
exponential of minus x
to B. Kappa of x prime
vx prime goes into--
a decay in exponential you can
follow into the other region.
And that's what we
do here, as before.
The decaying exponential
is safe because if you
know there's just a
decaying exponential,
there's no possibility of
having the growing exponential.
So these are your conditions
for that turning point,
and that's how you use them.
So one example that we will
not get to discuss now,
but will be in the notes, is
tunneling across a barrier.
And you will use the connection
conditions in this case
here, and for this case, the
other ones that we've done.
So you need for tunneling
both connection conditions.
It's a very nice exercise.
I recommend that
you play with it,
and we'll put it in
the notes as well.
So let's stop here.